on dirait qu'il dort chanteau deux
voisines et rien qui était la demeure
des comtes voire en les fils de long du
mall climat y est que même les barons
perte était la branche qu'on tarde des
barons jolicoeur au servian enfants
rater l'école à la bombe ou redoutent
aussi vous suivez pas vocation
oui oui je sais pas mais je n'arrive par
terre vous regardez vos autres jusqu'à
la grand mère écoutez suivez moi vous
riez garder les enfants et sans sage
vitry paix des braves au basket oui
d'été les enfants raté des crânes à
grand-bourg un même descendant du roi
des enfants dans son lit y à propos de
lille en montrant rien dans lequel l
espace et des trucs et des machins à la
fois osé écrire sur les cartes postales
à cause des bouses double porte de
choses légères on imposerait historique
non enfin entre nous je vous tienne de
poitiers et henry 2 un pic pas un ils
ont fait la fortune des menuisiers par
ici avec ma famille mais même si je suis
à toulouse un instant dans cette salle
qui était restaurée sur la restauration
et qui servait de restaurants à partir
de france mais a promis la poudre et mon
pied
là il y avait quelque chose de bouquets
des cancers en 9 89 et en 48 ans cat
rectification en cas de 48 ans la suite
jamais su ce que c'était mais cette
veine poux est très rare christian la
pub parisien location vous êtes payé le
poisson est plongée gratuits sont les
murs mais mais qu'est ce que vous allez
me baby c'est le chauffage central par
paresse il a continué ce jour là mais
j'ai ici un petit tableau c'est vous
avez ici les arts de la scène et a
compté entre premier et ici
grand tableau c'est un chef de francs
le grand bar blanc rouge c'est richelieu
est actuellement guérie trip des papiers
c'est son père jose est plus jeune que
le fils et sincères histoire il ya des
choses qui vont pas chercher à compenser
comme dit ma femme avait visité une
bonne chanson i 1 viennent de poitiers
henry de la pop et des merisiers ça mais
vous allez par la non si les labyrinthes
jusqu'à l'épaule château restée ici mais
m'est donnée le 28 mai mais dans la main
mais mais mais mais la main mais mais
même si les cieux sortant quelques-uns
dans cette cour d'abord pour que je vois
si là je puis les films toujours ce qui
pourra plus radio mijote et d'autre part
nous penchons ensemble au dessus des
swaps lui mémé ou penché pas trop s'il
n'en a pas parlé basket mais même comme
ça sur des prises
non messieurs celui-là parents sont à
vienne malgré ce montois en plexiglas et
son pourtour en duralumin et d'un puits
qui a été commencé de construire en tous
sens 12 par les espagnols continuant à
13 cents à 13 par les portugais ont
repris ensuite en 14 114 par les
prisonniers autrichien est terminée
aucun 115 par les espagnols qui étaient
revenus pour le finir ils cherchaient de
l'eau mais ne trouvèrent que de l'ombre
sont mortes quelques 8 mai mais quoi élu
recette qui lui ramène créneau ce moment
qu'un quart une chercher de l'eau pour
boire et à propos du mot pour voir
rappelez moi de vous dire quelque chose
en sorte
et se plie et rester français depuis on
aime rester religieusement français
carole x est un patrimoine
mais la mission continue colle à la
continuation ici derrière cette porte
j'ai pour la toux d'ailleurs même si
j'avais joué répond il y a des trésors
defamille aux rides est magnifique
il ya des coureurs en forme de couronne
des mutuelles des orientaux et relie
arrêt parce que depuis le temps il y
avait des trésors d or des jaunes et des
colliers et avaient le collier de diane
de poitiers sursis rend le travail de
huit kilos quand 45 et poupe de rang en
69 et plus car on est à lui joué vite de
perles et y ait un accord je me suis pas
méfiée n'était que jamais mais bon mais
y'a plus qu'à me faire rager vous la
montre voici la perle de diane de
poitiers
attention en effet pas les mensonges
c'est là où est la perle haut où l
affaire mais mais mais non c'est pas bon
mais mais
messieurs quand ils m'ont encore la
visite
mais arrêtons nous quelques instants
devant cette fenêtre qui était ouverte à
votre attention en vous penchant à
gauche
non mais mais pas droite à gauche ah oui
c'est bien oui rien par là et n'ont en
revanche pas bon vous apercevez la tour
la fameuse tour du président président
d'atout comme c'est écrit dans les dix
mille eddy mitchell et bien c'est très
joli plat tout c'est vous ce qu'il a
fait ce type nourri logé blanchi pas de
loyer pas d'être ici tu es en remerciant
c'est ce qu'il a fait il s'est arrêté
il s'appelle monde antenne le comte de
monte cristo on écoute et vous apercevez
en vous penchant un peu plus mais vous
apercevrez une statue en marbre
c'est marguerite me pour publier la
patronne des cueilleurs de fille qu elle
est en larmes et à côté vous voyez une
autre forme en noir c'est ma femme
mathilde qui revient du charbon avec ces
deux clubs en matinée revenus à venir
qui est venu mon coeur va bien compensé
à table et qu'elle a visé déterminé
messieurs n'oubliez pas le guide s'il
vous plaît vous avez passé quelques
instants au menu des arts des arts des
lettres et éloi n'oubliez pas guide ses
pas qu'ils aiment le 15 mai à parler
sans arrêt qui fait cela merci le pro
des francs suisses tenir ce jeudi
la grand-mère au bar la définit délit
mais me fait la planche bien vous en
faites pas je la reprendre en nocturne